Choose your neckline template based
on the size you want your neckline to be.
Now be sure to leave some room for your
bands, so make it wide enough so that you
have room for your bands and then
we'll just cut around this template.
I want to make my neckline
say 5 inches deep.
So let's say one, two, three, four, five.
I'm going to cut along
that five inch mark.
And then just hold the template up to your
knitting and let's say that this is
blocked and we would have that top line
of the template along with the top edge
of the knitting. Take a marker and mark
around the outside of that curve.
So you have a nice, smooth curve.
And you would use that for your cut 'n sew that line is where you would stitch
with the sewing machine or a serger.
And then cut out that neckline
and complete your cut 'n sew